okay so people were a little bit chafed
about the Forgotten albums minisode and
even though there were some album
recommend and even though there were
some album recommendations at the start
snuck in all stealthy like they were
just name dropped without any meat so
here's some meat to my canadian
listeners born before 1987 or so you're
probably already familiar with a lot of
these bands and albums so I'm sorry
about that
this is going to heavily assume that
you're from not Canada first Econoline
crush the devil you know harder rock
they'll probably still considered
mainstream highlights of the album
includes surefire title track the devil
you know and razor blades and band-aids
I don't really have a lot to say about
this album just I think it's held up
well since 1998 so give it a listen and
see if you enjoy it chaos yes
slick groove hip hop from a Toronto
native released in 2009 yes is the
fourth studio album from chaos
highlights include Zamboni 4 3 2 1 and
the confusingly named I wish I knew
natalie portman which samples phantom
planets California as its backbone a
great album for long drives the Tea
Party transmission released in 1997 it's
really hard for me to select highlights
from this album it's just solid from end
to end
temptation release transmission Babylon
emerald aftermath this album was huge
for me back at a time when disc mins
were still a thing this album routinely
stayed in for days or weeks at a time
in a lot of ways this album is a sort of
polished second draft of what to land
Nine Inch Nails were doing at the time
it's also a lot less I don't know how to
say this without sounding like a disc
I like these bands I like to lie like
Nine Inch Nails but it's a lot less
mopey and grim honestly think the
fragile if it had been recorded by Rush
instead of all the albums on this list
this is the one most intended to be
listened to as a complete thing with
unlisted tracks hidden the pre gap
between songs and an overall consistency
and flow that really rewards approaching
it as a complete presentation it's also
not the most car stereo friendly with
heavy uses of silence wide tonality and
sweeps from loud to quiet so you might
want to bust out the headphones for this
one
Obie's you beacons pop folk from a
now-defunct band released in 2009 this
album really is the best elements of
decade in d-wave mellow lush and
personal it's a really good trip though
the standout is hands down the track new
year if there is any one song as part of
this whole episode that I think you
should check out this is it
the tragically hip day for night okay so
this one's going to seem really weird to
tell my Canadian viewers like even
weirder than chaos or the Tea Party The
Tragically Hip are a Canadian
institution they've been around for 32
years they have 14 studio albums over 50
radio singles they sell out arenas and
because of that they've really become
the background radiation of Canadiana
they're just there and they've produced
so much over 30 years that like the
Rolling Stones Bob Dylan and Aerosmith
it can be hard to think of their output
as anything other than a total sum or
just skimming the best off the top and
despite all that if you're not from
Canada you or maybe just sort of barely
aware that they exist so I'm going to
toss the 1994 album day for night into
the pot here
highlights grace - so hard done by a
nautical disaster if you're looking for
an entry point into the intimidating
discography of the hip then this album
and 1998's phantom power are probably
your best bets dramarama cinema verite
will leave off with this one an obscure
classic from 1985 a super solid mix of
brit rock post-punk and pre grunge
influences this is a solid alt rock
album that never really found its
foothold I know I already said that new
years the number one must check out from
these recommendations but number two by
a hair's breadth is the album highlight
anything anything so there you go some
recommendations I hope that satisfies
you thank you for watching and as always
go and peace my children the name of
like share and subscribe
amen